i think about uh the great rich eisen
and his career and his life and
maybe how his life changed when he
joined the nfl network or
when he had his first child and i wonder
how yesterday changed for him rich where
were you when you found out that carmelo
joined the lakers
oh wow let me think about it yeah i
don't remember
rich this is what we've been dealing
with all day today
you know what it's it's just uh you know
look uh ben um i think you should um
you know just take care of your own
house
and hope and hope that um evan fournier
is worth all the dolan dollars that he
said yes to
and uh and and and the third time the
charm
for uh a frenchman after frederick vice
and
frank militina hopefully the knicks have
gotten it right
uh from france i don't know where magic
lumpy's passport is from but yes we'll
go with those big three uh for the
french knicks
uh hey talking basketball and some tokyo
gold brianna stewart put on a show
last night and i'm thinking about the
two best american basketball players
right now kevin durant
brianna stewart they're both coming off
of achilles a torn achilles it's
incredible
what do you make of the team usa women
and and what brianna's doing out in
japan
well i can only hope that the men have
as easy a time with the australians as
the women did
right um you know and um
we uh we did a lead in today uh to
promote the fact that men's is against
australia tomorrow and
leading into the women's highlight um
very heavy on the men at work
uh references um the winner was the
semifinals of
loser gets a vegemite sandwich those are
words i said today
um dating myself quite frankly 40 year
old music
um so look man she's one of the best uh
on planet earth and
you know um so uh we'll see what the men
do tomorrow i'm i'm genuinely nervous
about that patty mills joe ingles this
is no joke this is the real deal
and um we'll see how it goes yeah
definitely
feeling a little anxious for that one uh
what other events are are on the docket
right now that have you really excited
because after briana put on her show
in the game they cut right to diving and
then boom i'm locked in
and it's just incredible to lose
yourself in these sports
what's one that you kind of have circled
as we head towards the home stretch of
the olympics
oh the decathlon is just starting the
heptathlon's just starting i love that
stuff
uh i can't get enough of it um oh
there's there's a
an event that somebody's already won
gold for
and that's uh predicting the colts are
probably going to reach out to philip
rivers
um i'm uh i'm listening to the rich
eisen show and from being played
as i'm standing the top of the podium
with that gold around my neck
you know it's true yeah he responded he
acknowledged
this does it recognize your greatest
performance
although i did mention this to somebody
who's uh
very locked in in the football community
and
they said that they had a better
throwing arm than phillip rivers and
they've never played professional
quarterback and they're over the age of
50.
so um we'll see how that one plays out
um but uh man i i
this is unprecedented um yes we've seen
quarterbacks go down to training camp
and we have seen all pro
offensive lineman go down in training
camp we've never seen them go down
uh at the same time with a similar
injury and the same
whacked out uh designation of five to
twelve weeks we've never seen that
before
and so why not philip rivers coming back
trying it one more time getting that arm
ready coming on out of the smoke
and going back there it would be
definitely cheaper than
um going to get nick foles and having
nick stand there while wence
is there that that's something that
might consider the colts might consider
just
that wence is their guy they believe the
medical reports to come back
he will be back within three months
potentially and
three months from here right in the
middle of the season
and philip might be able to get him
through that and then philip is just
you know there is uh to break glass and
get these other youngsters up
to speed in the room that might be the
better move for the colts rich because i
know you're locked into this draftking
sportsbook posted odds today on who's
going to be the starter week one
for indianapolis nick foles your front
runner
jacob eason not even on the list gardner
minchu and blake bortles
have odds and know jacob eason who's
actually the starter at this moment
i don't know somebody knows something we
don't know i don't know i don't either
that's pretty wild yeah that is pretty
wild but
um exciting times everything's going
well here in connecticut i hop on a
flight tomorrow to go to ohio
yeah for the pro football hall of fame
where apparently
they are preparing to start to play
music seven minutes into everybody's
speech
wow good luck with that no chance that
is apparently
on the docket oh my god this weekend in
ohio
how about them apples not exactly the
best idea
but this is the beginning of the uh the
dallas cowboys nine and eight season for
tj very exciting we're looking
forward to it kicks off tomorrow night
memories get the promotional t-shirt and
video ready to go at the end of the year
huh
yeah that's great yeah baby great job
how about them cowboys it'll be good we
appreciate you calling in on your own
show thanks so much come on
energizing have a good rest of the show
guys thank you
thanks so much thank you appreciate it
rich first time long time rich eisen
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here